En varios videos hemos trabajado con ecuaciones
como esta y hemos intentado resolver para x. Lo
que vamos a hacer en este video es profundizar
un poco nuestra comprensión sobre lo que sucede
en ellas y pensar, sobre todo, en la noción de
equivalencia o de enunciados equivalentes. Pero,
¿a qué nos referimos con equivalencia? Bueno,
vamos a utilizar esta ecuación que tenemos aquí
para reescribirla de varias formas equivalentes y
hablaremos un poco más sobre lo que eso significa.
Una cosa que podemos hacer para escribir
un enunciado con la misma equivalencia es
distribuir este 3 en x + 1 y, por lo tanto, esta
parte se puede reescribir como: 3 x + 3 y después
tenemos -x = 9. Bien, lo que podría ser obvio de
alguna forma es que la ecuación de arriba y la
segunda ecuación son equivalentes. ¿Qué significa
eso? Significa que si una de ellas es
verdadera para una x dada, la otra también será
verdadera para la misma x y viceversa. Y podemos
escribir otros enunciados equivalentes. Por
ejemplo, si combinamos los términos con x,
es decir, si reducimos 3 x con -x, podemos
reescribirlos como 2x y además tenemos + 3 = 9.
Ahora, los tres enunciados son equivalentes:
si existe una x que cumple que 2x + 3 = 9,
entonces también es la misma x que cumple que 3 (x
+ 1) - x = 9 y viceversa: si existe una x que haga
verdadera la ecuación de arriba, entonces la misma
x hará verdadera la última ecuación. Y como ya
hemos visto antes, podemos hacer otras operaciones
que preserven la equivalencia. Podemos restar 3
de ambos lados, en general si sumas o restas
el mismo valor de ambos lados de la ecuación,
la equivalencia se preserva; si distribuimos
un valor como lo hicimos en el primer paso,
la equivalencia se preserva; si combinamos
términos semejantes, la equivalencia se
preserva. Y por acá haremos una operación que
preserve la equivalencia: vamos a restar 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y obtenemos 2x
= 6. Una vez más: cualquier x que satisfaga
esta última ecuación también va a satisfacer
cualquiera de las otras ecuaciones y viceversa,
cualquier x que satisfaga cualquiera de estas
ecuaciones también va a satisfacer la última,
son equivalentes entre ellas. Ahora, otra
operación que preserva la equivalencia es
multiplicar o dividir por una constante distinta
de 0. Por aquí podemos dividir ambos lados por 2,
2 es distinto de 0 y es una constante, y si
hacemos eso tendremos otro enunciado equivalente:
x = 3, así que cualquier x que satisfaga esto, que
sólo es x = 3, va a satisfacer todas las demás, y
cualquier x que satisfaga todas las demás también
va a satisfacer la última. Entonces, todas estas
son equivalentes. Así que una forma de pensar en
esto es que, sumar o restar el mismo número de
ambos lados de la ecuación, multiplicar o dividir
de ambos lados por una constante distinta de 0,
distribuir como hicimos en el primer paso o
combinar y reducir términos semejantes, preserva
la equivalencia. Ahora, seguro te preguntas ¿qué
operaciones no preservan la equivalencia? Bueno,
imagina algo así, empecemos con algo bastante
obvio: si digo que x = 2 y pensamos en una
operación que no preserva la equivalencia,
sería sumar o restar o multiplicar o dividir
por un valor sólo en un lado de la ecuación.
Imagina que sólo sumamos 1 del lado izquierdo,
entonces tenemos que x + 1 = 2. Y en este caso,
lo que satisface esta ecuación no satisface
también la ecuación de arriba ni viceversa: x =
2 claramente satisface la ecuación de arriba pero
no satisface la segunda. La razón es que hicimos
una operación que no preserva la equivalencia. De
la misma forma, si sólo multiplico por 3 el lado
derecho de la ecuación, obtendré x = 6; bueno,
al multiplicar por un valor sólo el lado derecho
lo que satisfaga x = 6 no va a satisfacer x = 2,
esto es algo obvio. Ahora, también hay otros
escenarios un poco más intrincados. Digamos
que tenemos la ecuación 5x = 6x. Bueno, podemos
estar tentados a querer hacer lo mismo de ambos
lados de la ecuación y dividir ambos lados
entre x. ¿Qué pasaría en ese escenario? Bueno,
si dividimos a ambos lados entre x podemos
pensar que un enunciado equivalente sería 5 = 6,
y ya sabemos que no existe ninguna x para la cual
5 sea igual a 6, no podemos hacer 5 = 6 o 6 = 5,
¿cierto? Si suponemos que estos son enunciados
equivalentes y decimos que no existe ninguna x que
satisfaga la segunda ecuación, 5 = 6, entonces
tal vez no exista ninguna x que satisfaga la
ecuación de arriba. Pero esta no es una operación
que preserva la equivalencia, porque, de hecho,
estamos trabajando en un escenario donde x = 0
y estaríamos dividiendo entre 0, así que debemos
tener mucho cuidado cuando dividimos entre
una variable, especialmente si el valor de
la variable que hace verdadera una ecuación es 0.
Entonces, para ser claros, si queremos preservar
la equivalencia por aquí, la forma de resolver
esta ecuación es restar 5x de ambos lados,
como sabemos esta es una operación que preserva
la equivalencia: restamos esta expresión de ambos
lados y nos quedaremos con que 0 = x. Y ahora,
x = 0 y 5x = 6x son enunciados equivalentes, son
ecuaciones equivalentes: cualquier x que haga esto
verdadero hará también esto verdadero, y cualquier
x que haga verdadera la ecuación de arriba también
hará verdadera la ecuación de abajo. Por último,
tal vez me escuchaste decir que si multiplicamos
o dividimos por una constante distinta de 0,
entonces se preserva la equivalencia, y espero
que ya tengas una idea de por qué no es buena
idea dividir entre 0, de hecho el resultado de
dividir entre 0 siempre será una cosa extraña y
es indefinido, pero también lo es multiplicar por
0. Por ejemplo, si tenemos... empecemos por aquí:
2x = 6 y multiplico ambos lados por 0, obtenemos
que 0 = 0 y 0 = 0 es verdadero para toda x 0
siempre va a ser igual a 0, pero el problema es
que el primer enunciado no es verdadero para toda
x, sólo es cierto para x = 3, así que estos no
son enunciados equivalentes, tienen un conjunto
distinto de x que los satisfacen. Por lo tanto,
debes tener mucho cuidado cuando trabajes con
cosas que son 0, podemos sumar o restar 0, aunque
obviamente eso no va a cambiar mucho las cosas,
pero si multiplicamos de ambos lados por
0 tendremos enunciados no equivalentes,
y multiplicar o dividir por variables que
podrían ser 0 también es un juego peligroso.